gaslighting looks like literally like i
said when somebody kind of denies your
reality so
you might say something like
i feel really sad that you said that to
me and they'd say something like you
have no right to say that you have no
right to feel that way or they'll say
something you'll have an argument with
them
and
they will have said something terrible
to you a couple of days before and
you'll say listen when you said they'll
say i never said that
and so it's literally like they deny
your reality and when somebody says i
never said that most normal people tend
to question themselves
and so in fact i always say one of the
ringers
that you're in a relationship with a
narcissist who's gaslighting you is you
start feeling the need to voice record
your conversations with them so you can
play it back to them i always say once
you feel like you need voice memos in a
relationship it may be time to get out
wanna be happy build a life not just the
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn the 10
behaviors that you should never tolerate
in a relationship
enjoy
behavior number two is don't validate
abuse with brendon burchard the time to
quit on somebody hands down
as harsh it might sound is
straightforward and honest and that's
when there's any abuse
when there's abuse in a relationship you
quit
period you owe no
loyalty
to abusive people
period
that's the time you got to get out and
that's where a lot of these questions
come from you know there's a lot of
domestic violence in the world there's a
lot of you know women who are treated
very very poorly and often physically
beaten up by their husbands by their
partners their spouses their lovers and
it's a bad bad deal and often these
women or these folks who are being
abused do not get the straightforward
answer and the straightforward answer is
if you're being abused physically quit
period leave that person get out of that
relationship get somewhere safe go to
your parents house if they're safe go to
a friend's house but you need to exit
not a month from now not three months
from now it needs to be immediate and it
needs to be swift and it has to be with
bold precision you need to plan it and
do it and you need to do it sooner than
later
and that's so hard to tell people
because
you know we have this often misaligned
thought in our head about loyalty
well if i leave this person then
you know i'll never be loved or if i
leave this person it's unfair to them
because they hung out with me and i'm a
you know piece of crap we make up these
stories to validate people's
injustice to us sometimes and at an
abuse level we can't do that and i know
your heart's in the same place as mine
in hearing this and it's difficult to do
but you have to do it
if anyone is being verbally
or physically abusive with you on a
consistent basis
get out and you don't need to wait for
consistency over a year or two or three
you're talking about one or two times
and you got to go
you have to remember there's seven
billion people on the planet there's
going to be someone who's going to treat
you better there's going to be somebody
who you can trust there's going to be
somebody who you know might not come
into your life until you create the
white space of getting rid of the the
bad folks
so the good folks can come in again
and it's necessary
and i hope you just hear me if you're in
an abusive situation
please leave sooner than later it's
always going to be the better decision
to leave sooner than later plan it out
find that place of support and go
behavior number three get rid of toxic
customers with lisa nichols every
relationship is a relay
it's like my dad's played tennis for
over 40 years and and i've attempted to
play with him at times and what i
realized is that relationships are like
a tennis match i hit the ball to you
you hit the ball back
and a relationship where you think it's
only about one person that's not tennis
that's racquetball
right but a relationship is a tennis
match and so if a relationship is
working it's because of the way we both
are engaging
if it's truly working and if it's not
working
it's the way we both are engaging and so
there could be passive engagement
and there could be active engagement so
when you're not speaking up for what you
want when you're holding and you're
living with a bunch of withholds that's
engagement that's just the way you're
engaging so
so
every relationship has two parts whether
your part is active or your part is
passive every relationship has
engagement a level of engagement and
that engagement is on different levels
if you find that the relationships
around you have toxic outcomes but i
want you to look at where is the
breakdown is the breakdown in
communication is the breakdown and how
you communicate the words you're using
is the breakdown in who you choose to be
around
is the breakdown in the engagement of
what you're talking about
what i've learned is that if you're not
talking about things that are high
enough and big enough
things that are inspiring enough you
will slip into the smallness
every single time if you don't choose an
intentionally high evolving encouraging
conversation you will slip into the
cracks you will slip into those crevices
of smallness and petty and until you get
people trained that you're going to live
up here without telling them i need you
to know it's not an announcement it's a
way of being and so what do you choose
to participate in it's a stepping over
your desire to hear smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook
did you stop the conversation
did you say hold on i don't want to
engage in speaking negatively of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk
at the risk of losing the relationship
but what you basically do is is you say
here's where i play
here is where i live i'm not visiting
this high road of integrity i'm not
visiting this high road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity
and people i don't visit this place i
live here
i don't visit this place
i live here
and in a loving way anyone that's
engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here
or they choose to engage with someone
else
now if you find
that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger or
you're in a moment of resentment or
you're in a moment of hurt then you're
not living in your highest integrity you
just visit every now and again when you
come to this channel
uh-oh i see my my
my shantae coming out right now shantae
is my middle name it's what i do when i
start getting real edgy because i really
want you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside
and then you don't leave your conscious
neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as
yours people will rise to the occasion
or they'll choose not to rise and
they'll pick other people to be with and
hang with and i know that sounds easier
said than done because some of the
people who are playing at a lower level
might be in family it might be and
that's fine too you can love people
it doesn't mean you have to spend tons
and tons and tons of time if that time
costs you something
spend as much time as you can spend as
much time as serves you spend as much
time as they will allow you to spend but
never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line
and
supporting you to either recognize are
you the toxic element are you
surrounding yourself in toxic element is
to make a commitment where you live
where am i living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what i do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness
that's powerful
own it and then go where do i want to be
and then what's the distance between
here and there and what do i have to do
to get there
what i have to say no to do i have to
participate in what i have to ask
forgiveness for what i have to clean up
what relationships require cleaning up
and then what declarations must i make
and what decisions must i live in don't
make a decision
living your decision behavior number
four is do not accept the unacceptable
with leon levanzant you don't have to be
broke
you don't have to struggle
you don't have to be sad and sorry you
don't have to take care of everybody
just because you've always done it be
willing to do a new thing in a new way
and sometimes you're gonna have to piss
people off in the process
[Music]
sometimes
[Applause]
because people will hold you to your
limitations
they will hold you to what they believe
to be true about you
spiritual code of conduct says
do not believe that because it hasn't
happened it won't happen renew recharge
your vision and do not be tricked into
thinking that because it's always
happened
it has to continue to happen
spiritual code of conduct says
do not accept the unacceptable
do not accommodate and tolerate what
doesn't honor you
spiritual code of conduct says don't let
people lie to you
you know when somebody is lying to you
you just don't know how to respond
so i'mma give you a response
this the iana responds to people lying
to you
you just look at him just as nice as you
can
and you say
beloved
[Applause]
[Music]
i know you think that's true
but something in here is not ringing
true for me
so i'm not gonna move until it feels
better in my belly
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there behavior number five is beware of
contempt with estelle parallel
indifference
and contempt
and neglect
and violence are probably the four most
important okay i'm not talking about big
violence microaggressions are plenty
indifference when you start to feel like
the other person fundamentally is not
really caring about you anymore or you
don't care about them what they feel
what they think who they are what
they're about
don't care you've lost interest but it's
more than losing of interest it's also
when you are doing different you degrade
the other person they're less important
to you they don't matter and ultimately
what we feel in relationships is that we
matter that is the essential reason for
connecting to people is that we are
creatures of meaning right i matter to
you i'm someone you care about me you
want my mail you want my well-being
you're proud of me you you want good for
me you're benevolent all of that when
you are indifferent the whole thing goes
and then you start to this that coldness
that creeps in that sense of
estrangement that complete disconnect
that the second one is neglect neglect
when people just basically take each
other for granted you know they take
more care of their car than of their
partner their dog or their dog anybody
anything their yard anything anything
gets attendants
their business for sure their business
for sure you know everything gets
priority everything gets reviewed
evaluated attended to 360s you name it
you know new input
my god it's like people have this idea
that they put it all in when they were
dating
and then once they seal the knot it's
like as if they tied the knot it's like
now they don't have to do squat anymore
and they go into this kind of complete
sense of complacency and laziness
it's an amazing thing they think this
thing is just going to live on its own
right
like a cactus right violence violence
the abuse the level of of disrespect i
mean most people talk nicer to anybody
else than their partner when a
relationship
because you can't get away with it
because you can't get away with it
because if you talk like this at work
you're gone
because if you talk like this with the
police you're gone because if you talk
like this on the street you're being
punched
but with your partner you have that
sense that they're gonna be there anyway
they're just gonna take it because it's
family and family is this kind of this
thing that doesn't dissolve so easily so
you can just lash out at them and talk
to them with a tone and a dismissal that
is phenomenal so that kind of violence
i'm not talking physical violence and
all the other big big things you're
talking about aggression or resentment
or all of that yeah all of that you know
passive aggressiveness all those things
yeah all of that and then and then um
contempt i think is the top one
contempt is the killer of them all right
because in in the contempt there is a
real
there's the degradation of there is is
that that complete this you're nothing
you're nothing i can kill you with that
one guess that one eyebrow that goes up
you know stuff do you who do you think
you are what are and that's it you
you're done behavior number six don't
allow invasion with maya angelou there's
a place in you
that you must keep
in violate you must keep it
pristine clean
so that nobody has the right to curse
you up treat you badly nobody no mother
father no wife no husband knows nobody
because that may be the place you go to
when you meet god
you have to have a place with did you
say stop it
back up
not he
no
absolutely and that's one i told you
25 years ago yes say no when it's no
yeah say so back it up because that
place has to remain clean and clear and
that has to be a place within you yes
ma'am yeah
that is the best advice behavior number
seven refuse to lose yourself with mel
robbins you either address the five
things i'm about to talk about in this
video
or face the truth
and end the relationship yourself
because it's over so what are the five
signs sign number one you don't feel
like yourself
in this relationship you feel like
you're walking on eggshells you don't
know how to act when you're in public or
when you're around their friends you
aren't sure if you should hold hands
you're uncomfortable talking about your
feelings because you don't know if
they're on the same page all of these
things mean
you don't feel comfortable being you
and any relationship where you have to
twist yourself into somebody that you're
not in order to keep the peace it only
starts a war inside of you and those
kind of relationships they always blow
up the second sign
you're constantly questioning
how you should communicate
if you're nervous about sending a text
asking if they want to hang out or do
you obsess over whether they opened your
snap but they haven't responded or how
long it's been since they texted you
back
do they watch your instagram story but
not respond to your text messages
are you compulsively checking social
media to try to get the clues you need
that it's okay to reach out
any relationship where you spend more
time questioning rather than talking
about communication is a relationship
that's broken sign number three
you think about where the relationship
stands all the time
so do you constantly think about
questions like where is this going are
we exclusive are we committed can i
introduce you to my family and take you
to a work event how should i introduce
you what are you thinking what do you
say about me
not knowing
where you stand means this relationship
doesn't stand a chance sign number four
you're starting to get annoyed
you're now the one opening snaps and not
responding
you're saying you're too busy to hang
out in order to send a message you're
hesitant to commit to future plans
because you don't know the future of
this relationship you snap at them more
than usual all those cute little things
that used to make you laugh they're
really annoying and here's the kiss of
death if their name pops up on your
phone or they walk through the door at
the end of the day and you feel dread
and not excitement
that's a sign
that you're over this person and the
fifth and final sign
you're questioning whether or not you
have the same values
if you're starting to feel like you're
losing yourself
for example maybe you're drinking more
than you'd like you're spending less
time with your friends you're skipping
the gym you're only doing things for
example like listening to certain types
of music because it interests them this
is a major problem
if there isn't a balance between the two
of you you will always feel like a less
important part of the relationship
because you are now here's a quick test
to see if you're losing yourself
just go out alone tonight with your
friends and if it feels like a relief
because you can finally act like
yourself that's a sign that this is not
a relationship for you
i bet what you're doing is you're
confusing chemistry for compatibility
you see chemistry is like a match that
gets lit
but eventually it burns out
compatibility means you and your partner
bring out the best in you which is why
it goes the distance behavior number
eight don't consume negativity with dave
hollis the first relationship that you
have to think differently about is media
media is an amazing thing
it is a pervasive thing an omnipresent
thing it is an everywhere thing it is
great until it isn't
if you are not conscientious of what you
are consuming in media it is consuming
you
if you are not on the regular doing an
audit of who you follow
of what you feel from what you watch
of how often you're spending time in
front of a screen
then you are not actively taking control
of how you can get to where you're
trying to head
if you consume negative things
you will be a negative person
if you consume positive things you will
be a positive person
i'm a news junkie i love the news
i love to catch up on all the new stuff
and then one day the news got crazy
i recognized that when i watched the
news in the morning i was unable to feel
inspired to go change the world in the
afternoon
it felt overwhelming
it felt like something that now was
working in opposition of what i needed
for actually pursuing my goals
so i stopped watching the news
now here's the thing i can still be an
active participant in the social
political world by doing other things
but watching the news was not a thing
that was serving me
if you aren't asking does this thing
that i watch does this person that i
follow
and by the way
if you go into your facebook account and
you're still following people from high
school that trigger you
you need to let go of shelley
shelley isn't a part of your life
anymore
it's been 20 years
let shelly go
it's okay to unfriend people
if following
your sister or mom
always throws you into a bad mood
find a way to connect with them in
person and not online you have
permission to unfollow the the voices
that are negative in your life it will
change
change your life behavior number nine
don't trust cheaters with tom bilyeu
what are your thoughts on cheating would
you give your partner a second chance so
to me like um i believe relationships
are sacred i believe that there's
literally the holy in a relationship and
and that there's a level of depth and
beauty to human connection that just it
just isn't paralleled anywhere else
um but i don't believe that their um
that
they need to be forever if they're not
functional and so there's certain things
that i look for in a relationship and if
i wasn't getting those things to me
there is no purpose in having that
relationship
and one of those is to feel like you're
somebody's number one and i think that's
probably the most intoxicating thing
about a relationship that's why
marriage has lasted and i won't even ask
people to believe that that's the
natural natural state of things
if you look god if we can get really
weird for a minute if you look at the
shape of um
just in case there are people with kids
if you look at the shape of male
genitalia um the way that it has evolved
does not lead one to believe that we're
the most monogamous species we're
certainly not the least either um but
we're not the most
and so i
i don't even need that to like be true
that oh well we're built for monogamy
whether we're built from monogamy or not
to me is is completely irrelevant if you
have some a thing in the relationship
that establishes trust like let's say oh
you can sleep with whoever you want i
don't care but don't ever drink orange
juice
right if that were our thing and then
you drink the orange juice then i know
there's no trust in this relationship
and that is the other thing to me so
being somebody's number one like that's
absolutely critical i want to be
somebody's number one and then the other
is i need to know that i can trust them
because
to the emotional attack that one feels
when they they're
destabilized by not knowing if they can
trust the other person is so uniquely
horrible and it diminishes your sense of
self and
hopefully you guys understand this by
now about me anything that diminishes my
sense of self that makes me feel
less than who i am like i don't go for
that and so if somebody were treating me
without respect
in a way that i couldn't trust them
that's going to diminish me
i'm going to be paranoid i'm going to
feel small
and i don't go in on that so to me
whatever you've established as your line
of trust so for us it's
physical
and quite we've never stated emotional
abuse but i will say that it goes
without saying so abuse and then um
being you know uh infidelity so those
are the things that we've established as
lines of trust and you know if those
were broken then and behavior number ten
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is establish meaningful
connections with oprah winfrey you can't
get what you want by focusing on what
you don't want
this is about the need to
establish as many meaningful connections
as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way to connect to each other
to connect to the nature that we're
killing to animals to history to an
acknowledgement of the lingering trauma
of racism and sexism
we need to connect to the people we love
and mean something to us and more than
that to the people who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means
we if we're going to continue to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend the politics of
division
and embrace the places that bond us
where we find our human ground
and every time i was in a relationship
i kept saying to myself man i never feel
peace yeah
there was not one relationship where i'd
come home and i want to feel like
like clenched up when i get around them
because i just there's always going to
be an argument or always a conversation
or doubt or insecurity and i was like i
can't
keep trying to work
so much to have someone like increase
their confidence
and i said to myself and i remember
asking devon franklin who should
interview sometime
he
wrote a book called the wait
where he and his wife waited to have sex
before they were married okay right
they're both in hollywood you know it's
a big thing or whatever they wrote a
book called the wade
and i asked him i go when do you know
you found someone who could be the one
because i believe there's lots of women
in the world that i could be with
probably and have an amazing life with
but i was like when do you know you
found someone who could be an amazing
partner long term
without a hesitation he said when you
feel peace
and i was like wow i've never felt that
in a relationship i've always felt like
drama stress chaos
and it was also like a model that i had
growing up when i reflect back on what a
psychologist has said to me like
my parents were always fighting
one was more confident the other
one was the breadwinner the other one
was like more insecure wow there was a
lot of um
you know fights and then not taught
passive aggressiveness for weeks and
then coming back together and then
repeating that cycle over and over
that's kind of what i was doing in my
relationships i was trying to find
someone who was insecure and build them
up but i wasn't even aware of it i
wasn't even conscious about it i was
just attracted to someone for no reason
we just repeat the cycles i think if you
have a partner who doesn't support your
business you're either going to lose
your business you're going to lose your
partner
it's really hard to be mission driven
and want to have a successful company
and be in a relationship with somebody
who doesn't support you i think there's
four
buckets that people fall into two of
them are negative and two of them are
positive the two on the negative side
you have a partner who just absolutely
hates what you're doing
you have a partner who just doesn't
believe in what you're doing they hate
it they think you should quit they think
it's tearing down the family they just
don't want you to do anything with
related to that business and that really
sucks as a place to be you can't
continue on with your business and your
relationship you have to figure out a
way to make it happen
the second bucket is they tolerate it
they're not happy with it but they
tolerate it and that's also a really
tough place to be because any time
you are struggling anytime you're not
getting results any time you're coming
home when you're stressed out they're
going to say see see i told you that
business you shouldn't be doing it they
barely tolerate it but they're not on
your side they just do it because they
want you to have your thing and they
love you but they're not really on your
side and they don't want it to succeed
it's a really hard spot to be in if
that's you and an entrepreneur and that
being your partner it sucks
now moving to the positive side the next
step up
is they support you they support you
they believe in what you're doing they
may not be involved in it but they want
you to be happy they believe in your
mission they're they're pumped that
you're up doing your own thing and they
support you and you going off and
accomplishing your goal and then the
last one which is ideal in most
situations is you have someone who's a
champion and they champion you and they
want to be involved and they want to
help and they want to participate and
they're thinking about you and they're
they're trying to champion your cause
and so those four buckets
you have to be in the last two in my
opinion you have to be in a positive
territory with your partner otherwise
your relationship or your business will
not last long term so what can you do
now how can you move your partner from
being in that negative spot to being a
more positive one i'm gonna give you a
three-step process that i think will
help your business and your relationship
it looks like this support communicate
involve
support communicate and involve so step
one is support and what that means is
you support them support them first if
you are supporting them in their career
and their ambitions and their drive and
what they're looking for
you're much more likely to get support
back on you if you were just expecting
support 24 7 but you're not giving it
first it's really hard so if you want to
to get it back you want to receive start
by giving and so they may not want to be
an entrepreneur that may not be how you
support them but could you support them
in their career could you support them
in their friendships could you support
them in your relationship like what are
they after what are their goals what are
their aspirations what do they need help
with do they just need somebody to come
home and listen to them for half an hour
when they walk in the door what is it
what does support look like for them not
your version of it you know what you
want
what's their version of it and how can
you support them in accomplishing their
goals their ambitions their aspirations
you support them first and then you'll
get a little more support on your rent i
promise step number two is communicate
one of the biggest challenges with
entrepreneurs is we don't often
communicate to our partners what we're
going through what we're thinking about
what we're struggling with and this is
something that that nina and i struggled
with early on in our relationship nina's
where's nina nina's somewhere there
nina's somewhere there there's the hand
so
me i don't
need to share what's happening in my
life i don't need to doesn't doesn't
release any stress or attention or
energy if i'm working with something i
need to just figure it out and then i'll
get to the place where i have an answer
and i'm good
nina always wants to know what's
happening in my life she wanted to know
when she came home from work what
happened with me that day i don't even
remember what happened with me that day
i had to force myself to think about
what happened
and at the beginning that caused a
little bit of tension and so i made a
dedicated effort to say okay i'm gonna
think about what's happening in my life
what's happened my business i'm gonna
make an effort to tell nina first before
anybody else finds out she'd be upset if
she wasn't the first to know so i make
her the first to know and that extra
communication helps because she
understands my world a little bit better
even though she wasn't involved in my
world that much even though she didn't
know much about youtube or the things
that i'm working on she couldn't be an
asset to the business yet
just having her know
having her feel like she's involved in
the problems that i'm facing at that
time make everything easier so there was
an important youtube update that came
out or or something went wrong on the
channel and she knew about it she would
say hey do you need to go home and work
on it she understands now she's in my
corner so it's not the business being
the negative the business taking time
away from us my problem has become her
problem and my win has become her win
and so it allows her an entry point into
my world and so communicate you have to
communicate you got to set the rules you
got to explain what's going on i did an
event yesterday in indianapolis
and an entrepreneur came up at the end
and was talking to me about
how
he feels the same way where he's like
super stressed out at work and his
business and he comes home and he has no
more energy left and then he comes and
his wife wants to talk immediately about
what happened to him during the day and
he just wants some time to relax
and it causes a lot of tension at home
and he's frustrated and upset that he's
not bringing his best of himself at home
to his relationships so give him some
advice one
on your way home go with the intention
of how do you want the rest of your
evening to go
right you're just going home like an
accident go home with the intention of i
want to have a great night with my wife
two work on communicating explain if
you're stressed out say why you're
stressed out don't take it out on your
partner go home and say what happened to
you and why you're so stressed out
and by you explaining it you're bringing
her into your world she's more likely to
understand and support you that's how
you can get somebody from
just tolerating what you're doing to
supporting you because they see how
important it is to you and the
storytelling brings them into your world
and then three just the communication on
that part of maybe you need 20 minutes
to yourself when you come home
maybe you set some ground rules with
your wife and say hey i i want to tell
you everything i want to explain and be
fully transparent and let you to my
world when i come home i just need 20
minutes to myself
just to decompress just to relax and
then i'm in a much better spot
emotionally to be able to come and talk
and share what's on my mind chances are
she'd understand that
but you just set that up you set that
communication up before so that when you
come home it's not this giant fight
every night so step two in building a
better relationship is communication and
then step number three is involving them
see what you can do to involve them into
your business into your mission into
your values if there's a fit so i'm
filming this from an airbnb here in
indianapolis i made a commitment to my
wife and i said i'm going to take you to
every city in north america with a
million plus people i did that because
she'd like to travel and i like meeting
entrepreneurs so how about we combine
these things together nina loves
organizing events she loves putting on
events doing all the all the detail work
all that stuff that i'm not a huge fan
of but i didn't have a lot for her to do
in my business
right she didn't want to be in front of
the camera she didn't want to do youtube
stuff organizing events was not a big
part of what i did i do two events a
year in toronto one in may one in
september teaching people how to be
thought leaders and make money from it
and she definitely helped out a lot in
putting those events on and booking the
restaurants and all of that stuff she
was a huge lifesaver
but it's not enough to be heavily
involved it's definitely not a full-time
job so i said what if we found the way
to integrate it what if we combined your
love of traveling your love of
organizing events my love of helping
entrepreneurs and we smushed all that
together and we created this tour we
created this frankenstein creation where
i'm visiting in 90 days 23 different
cities
and that was a
co-collaboration right that was a
co-effort on our part to combine our
missions together what we love doing and
find a way to work together what's going
to happen in the 90 days i don't know
does nina go back and get another job i
don't know does nina find another path
to continue on in my business i don't
know we're going to be different people
by the end of the 90 days and so we're
open to be able to do more together and
so following that three-step process
thinking about how first you can support
them on what they're doing then thinking
about how you can communicate better
just to express what you're going
through and then three trying to figure
out how can you involve them more in
what you're doing not forcing them to do
something that they don't want to do but
finding an opportunity of how they can
combine their passion with your mission
as well i think makes for a much better
work-life integration and a happier
relationship as well as a business
everybody wants better relationships
because you and i both know when your
relationship sucks your life sucks but a
ton of people have terrible
relationships and they don't know why
and they're constantly fighting and
they're always in the argument mode
they're always like thinking the other
person isn't sufficient isn't delivering
for them isn't happy for them isn't
supportive enough and so you have all
these people who have like good people
in their lives but their relationships
suck and sometimes their relationship
sucks with their family or their friends
or it can be their significant other and
it's just like it makes you want to tear
your hair out so let me give you four
ideas that can actually help you improve
your relationships nurturing deeper
better relationships with anybody right
friends family or your significant other
your partner your lover so the first
idea is you never know a person if you
don't know their goals
and if you don't know their goals you're
never going to be a great friend
you'll never be their great lover their
great supporter their great family
member
and it's weird though because most
people actually don't know other
people's goals i'll ask family members
to say what what's your sister's goals
you know she wants to be a dancer okay
what kind of dancer when
what does she want to do with that
career is the short term is a long term
like you have to really get into
people's goals to understand their heart
and so that's what i want you to do is
if you want to be a great spouse to
somebody you got to re-engage and say
hey what do you want at this stage of
your life because i know i know what you
used to want then we had kids but where
are you at now
and you got to get that conversation
with your partner and say hey listen i
know we've been through a couple of
weird months where we just haven't
really felt each other out it's like
let's just do some personal development
like what do you really want to do right
now at this stage of your life because
you have to understand when i say this
stage of your life that's very specific
meaning a lot of people's goals change
and it changes like every three months
every year every three years so if you
haven't had the conversation with the
important people in your life recently
about what your goals are and about what
their goals are then i'm telling you
you're just skimming at the surface
because if you don't support other
people's dreams how can you ever have a
deep relationship with them and if you
don't share your dreams and your heart
and your desire with other people how
can they possibly help you meet that
hunger how can they possibly help you
become the best version of you if you
haven't shared it so you also have to be
very honest with what's your real
thoughts what's your real feelings
what's your real dreams what do you
really want at this stage of your life
with all the important people around you
it's one of my favorite things to do
with high performers to say okay do all
the people around you know what you
really want right now are they clear on
what your goals are are are they clear
about how they can support that or how
much you want them to be involved in it
it's like a lot of people start their
own business but they don't tell the
other people around them what that
business is what it requires how they
love their support and so we all go it
alone
and isn't going it alone the opposite of
having healthy supportive relationships
so first thing you got to do if you want
better relationships get to know other
people's goals i want to start with one
of the things that you have always said
is like the base and foundation to
relationships selection matters
so that's where i want to start um talk
to me about selection matters what you
mean by that
so
this is
i feel so bad because for a long time it
didn't dawn on me how important it was
and i just thought that i was like king
[ __ ] in relationships
um and then i really started to think
about
the way that you are in the relationship
and how would i be able to
apply the things that i'm learning from
reading books and all of that stuff
about how to make a relationship work if
you weren't so adept at
one just being good at
communicating too
you're so good at letting things go
and
realizing how much grace you were giving
me in the relationship to make mistakes
to try things that didn't necessarily
work or to just be plain young and
stupid i don't remember when it hit me
but i remember how it felt when i was
like wait a second
if i didn't have that then
all of the
knowledge and tools and tactics wouldn't
go anywhere if you didn't have a growth
mindset as well then this would really
be sort of dead in the water and it
really made me start to reflect on how
much of this is actually that i have
tools and tactics and how much of this
is that i just really
chose
wisely
and really began to realize you need
both for sure you need the tools you
need the tactics you need communication
the hard work that you were talking
about in the intro all of that's real
but you really need to
pick somebody that has certain sort of
objective universal characteristics like
um either already a growth mindset or a
willingness to pursue it i mean we got
together so young i don't think either i
know neither of us had a growth mindset
but we understood very early on that you
either grow together or you grow apart
so we put equal energy into improving
and then there are things that are
specific to you there are certain things
you're going to like not like
the fact that we're not both you know
just sort of alphas banging our heads
together that we found a nice yin yang
balance like you were talking about
people get what they accept people get
what they tolerate in themselves and
each other and most people in a
relationship are thinking about what
they're going to tolerate in the other
person but in our relationship i think
the the beauty and the passion and all
the juice that i've gotten experience in
our relationship with my girl is because
i hold myself to a higher standard that
she could ever expect of me and i think
when your standard and focus is about
yourself instead about your partner
about how do i show up more what am i
here to give in the beginning of a
relationship people's whole focus is how
do i light them up i want to do anything
that lights them up and it makes you
feel incredible like your partner up and
you know relationship is aging not based
on years but based on one you could be
with somebody a week but if you start
thinking about what are they doing for
me and i'm doing it all and you start
measuring what you're giving instead of
just giving from your heart and your
soul things drop off so maybe this week
is a chance for you to really create
some relationship breakthroughs and we
think that takes three things any kind
of breakthrough sometimes it's having
the right strategy because frankly you
know as a guy we say and do things that
girls interpret very differently they
come up with very different meanings and
vice versa you know for men for example
problems are not things you talk about
problems are things you solve right now
or you make them small and move on for
ladies sharing that problem digging in
feeling it not solving it understanding
it understanding gentlemen is such a key
piece we are such different species and
i think having an understanding of each
other and each other's needs and knowing
that we are not the same you know our
own reality of how we think and feel and
process life is isn't the same for your
partner so having that not just
understanding but truthfully
appreciation for how they view and
experience the world is a game-changer
is it game-changer there's so many
things in our relationship and it's like
oh my goodness you know what it's not me
because sometimes you take things
personally it's just knowing that that's
how they process reality and process
life when they say that it's not meant
for mars women for venus john gray is a
friend of mine that's a wonderful
approach but all men have a feminine
side and a masculine side all women have
a feminine side and a masculine side
it's really just understanding how this
species their different species
interpret the world and if you don't
understand the strategy of how to
interpret that you'll be upset or angry
or frustrated so perhaps this week and
you know you'll be able to dig in and
get some new understandings that'll take
some of the weight off and make you
laugh at stuff that you used to get
upset about how to make a relationship
work like it's not just magic you need
to kind of put in the work to make it
work it's hard to put in effort and yeah
compromise a lot of times on
like if you live by yourself you can do
everything the way you would want yeah
if you live with someone else then
there's compromises to make yes in the
long picture it's better for you well
that's that's it that's it there's
sacrifices to be made in the short term
yeah you know and i mean people
have to the effort issue is like
well when you're
in love with someone you're going to
organize your schedule and make them a
priority
and you know that's in some ways a
fleeting state although it's not
necessarily as fleeting as people think
it is but whatever
it's it's obviously a priority then you
get married and you know you kind of get
accustomed to having each other around
and then
everything else
is more important and the relationship
drifts to the bottom
and then people get dissatisfied and
they start looking for excitement and
venture otherwise well you can't do that
you have to prioritize the relationship
like my observation clinically has been
for a couple to maintain their
relationship without it deteriorating
they have to spend 90 minutes a week
together talking about their lives about
how the house is run about what they've
all been doing to keep their stories
caught up right it's not really even
that much but no it's not it's not it's
not that much yeah but but and which is
a good thing you can actually do it and
then they need to spend at least one
time
having
a date and two is better
one is
necessary two is better
you can't aim for a lot more than that
because you know life is very busy and
yeah if it's going to be sustainable it
has to be realistic
but
they need to make time for each other
twice a week and and talk in like in a
non-romantic way just practically about
the domestic economy and about
everything that's going on and that
keeps people
tied to each other and
updated and so that's sort of your
minimal commitment level if you don't
want things to deteriorate if you want
to change your relationship the number
one thing you have to do is master your
own emotions
if you don't do that forget it
there's no hope
and what's wonderful though is it's easy
to do if you know how but none of us
have been taught really emotional
leadership emotional management is the
very minimum much less how to direct and
shape ourselves i don't mean faking your
emotions i don't mean pushing them down
i don't believe in positive thinking
although you may think that from
watching you know some of the media
coverage i am not into positive thinking
i'm not here tonight to tell you to go
to your garden and say there's no weeds
there's no weeds there's no weeds
there's no weeds
you know
i'm very clear that i believe that life
is about leadership and being truthful
to yourself and so i believe number one
that the mandate for any great
relationship and a mandate for anybody
to leave their own life and not be a
follower is you got to see things as
they are
but not worse than they are
because that's where most people go
that's where they go on relationship
that's why they start to tear it down
that's why the relationship starts to
break down because people get scared
when is it working out and then they
make it worse than it is so they don't
have to try because they don't want to
try again and be disappointed they don't
want to feel that sense of rejection
they don't want to feel that sense of
failure so most people make it much
worse than it is people tell me all the
time oh i'm skeptical or i'm pessimistic
i said no no you're gutless
it takes no guts it takes no courage
to be a pessimist to say it's not going
to work to try to find out what's wrong
what's wrong is always available so
that's what's right
so i'm not into positive thinking but i
am into intelligence and intelligence
says see it as it is don't make it worse
than it is i mean people all the time
say um my problem is i'm big bone no
you're freaking fat tell the truth
you know what is this big bone story
you know
the only way it gets better is if you
can see how it is don't make it worse
than it is don't try and make it so it's
impossible to change that's not true
it's not true at all
the second mandate i think to changing
anything in your life to believe in your
life is once you see it as it is not
worse it is then you got to see it
better than it is
because that's the thing that's missing
for most relationships there's no vision
i mean without a vision in the bible it
says people what
perish and when a relationship has no
vision for greater than where they are
that relationship is going downhill if
not destroyed
i believe that every relationship every
part of life every part of a human being
needs a compelling future if the future
is not more compelling than today
today could be tough but if the future
is compelling we can get there and
that's what every leader does and every
one of you in this room and i know some
of you are here i guess from the general
public as well just for your own
relationship i really acknowledge you
for but i know you're from the military
here i know the therapists here people
from all walks of life you're all
leaders what's your job to lead your job
is to help people see it as it is not
worse than it is what's your job help
them create a compelling future see it
better than it is so there's a reason to
give my all again
otherwise there's just no juice there's
no energy why they'll go through the
motions complain with each other not
really believe it's going to work and
nothing will change and then finally the
third step that we've all got to do if
we're going to change our life or
anybody else's is make it the way we see
it
and that's where strategy comes in i try
to take things that are complex and make
him as simple as possible
i've noticed most people in the
psychological world try to make it as
complex as humanly possible
because it makes us feel so
sophisticated we can talk with all these
complex words and elements and so forth
and we can really you know we got our
degrees and we we're somebody but you
know what that doesn't help anybody so i
look for a nickel word to get to the
heart of something i'll try to take
something complex and make it simple so
that people really will apply it what
really is important though is if you
consistently feel like there's a loss of
attraction in the relationship it
changes your filter on each other's
behaviors and it goes to the second
stressor now all of a sudden with a loss
of attraction there's an increase in
irritation
yeah
people start to get very often where
they get emotionally stacked like little
things start to bug them in a worse case
they get to stonewalling so we'll give
an example there's four r's that we talk
about that actually this came out of a
couple of our friends who are both
relationship experts who got divorced
but they learned from that experience
and they both were trying to figure out
what destroyed their relationship and
they were sharing with us and they said
well the first thing is there's that
initial resistance
you know where somebody says something
or somebody does something your partner
doesn't you're like oh you know i wish
they wouldn't do that but you don't say
anything because you know you know it's
not appropriate to say anything it's not
that big a deal but if you don't deal
with the resistance level and you don't
always call it speaking on spokens if
you don't speak the unspokens and you
don't speak that resistance then that
resistance becomes the next and it
becomes a little bit deeper which is the
resentment and all of these unspokens in
the anchors and the stackings they all
go deeper yeah and what happens when it
starts to become a resentment the way
you kind of know that as you start going
why does he or why does she always have
to tell that story or you know why is he
always late or she always later why do
we have to go through this but you still
don't necessarily say much at that stage
and you feel any emotions sometimes you
just wake up in the morning and feel a
charge and you don't even know where it
came from and it's just that built up
what it was resistances that you didn't
do and by the way the resistances may
have just been your stuff absolutely but
the fact that you didn't come and say
gosh honey i know this is my stuff but i
was kind of reacting this thing it's not
you but i just want to tell you
i got to shift this or would you help me
with this if you just talk about it it's
different but if you don't that
resistance turns into resentment if that
resentment isn't dealt with it starts to
show up as rejection that's when
somebody starts going why do you always
do that
or they you know when you overreact to
somebody you're not reacting to this
moment you're reacting the fact that it
happened again in your mind and so
people by the way when you start
rejecting them or being really overly
harsh
they don't know why you're doing this
and so then they feel really wounded
they tend to then reject you back and it
spirals and even crazy eight that
happens or the rejection of you know i'm
out of here and you know p in that space
there's words that are spoken that it's
just there's that emotional charge
now we're getting in deeper and you're
getting a level with a level of charge
and honestly toxicity in the
relationship that you don't want and we
so stay in our relationship just with
these once again it's the awareness and
once you have this awareness you can see
where you are it's like you know what
i'm feeling resistance right now that
you can speak that unspokens and you
don't get to level three and four and my
girl has no difficulty expressing her
resistance
but the great thing seriously is we both
tease we have these little plate fights
where she'll say you know honey you're
driving me a little crazy right now or
i'll do the same thing with her but we
do it not from a harshness exactly yeah
and then it gets the energy out and then
you don't build it up so there is a
fourth level but uh we're out of time so
uh we'll see you tomorrow seriously
okay here we go
is when you get to a place where now
you're oppressing in other words
resistance grew to resentment resentment
got yourself to a point of rejection
where you're kind of being harsh with
each other some people get tired of
being harsh with each other and they
just surrender and they're just numb
that's right they're going to what we
call learned helplessness where it's
just like not going to get any better
it's how it is and those times very
often when other couples meet them
they'll say those guys they're best
friends they're great they're neutral
again they never they never fight
you know that's the first thing they
never the faculty never bites a little
clue right very benign because what they
do is they lower their expectation for
the relationship and they start filling
up through their work or through their
kids or through shopping or through
something else and what happens in that
relationship is it's really dead
um
or maybe it's a decent friendship but
you'll be friends with anybody again you
can't be intimate with anybody so we're
this our whole thing is about love and
passion not settling for one or the
other like taking it up in a notch and
so breaking the pattern of these four
r's is really critical the other day one
of my friends asked me just what is a
healthy relationship you know i had to
scratch my head for a minute because i
realize that there are many many people
who have no clue what it is
what it means what it takes to have a
healthy relationship a healthy
relationship is one you want to be in
not one that you are in or have been in
so long you don't know how to leave or
one that you used to being in or one
that you're in out of habit or
obligation or a sense of responsibility
a healthy relationship is one that you
want to be in because it is good for you
and the other people involved which
brings us to the second element
a healthy relationship is one in which
you feel affirmed
supported and encouraged to be the best
person you can be
in fact a healthy relationship makes you
want to be a better person this means
that you can be your authentic self your
real self at all times with the person
you're in relationship with you have
your strengths that are recognized in
your weaknesses and shortcomings that
are
accepted not criticized but that you're
also supported in working out and
working through
you have your individual talents and
interests that are supported and your
voice your view your needs are
considered in the things that you do
together in a healthy relationship you
get to be you
as you change and shift and grow without
being expected to be who the other
person or people need and want you to be
in order to keep them comfortable
i think another sign of a healthy
relationship is that there's trust
honesty respect
compassion forgiveness compromise and a
shared vision
shared interest and a willingness to
practice all of those principles and
live up to them to the best of your
ability a healthy relationship is also
the one that you're prepared to work for
and work on yes a healthy relationship
requires a lot of work however when you
want to be in the relationship when
you're passionate about the relationship
and its health it won't seem like work
at all
a relationship is a living thing
it needs to be nurtured and nourished
and if you want to keep the relationship
healthy you can't just sit back and wait
for the good times to roll in you need
to initiate it this means you have to
look for ways to create happy memories
all of the time even if it means doing
something silly that you both enjoy
remember that a relationship is a living
thing
it moves and breathes in the heart of
the people involved so when people
neglect the life of the relationship
those with whom you are having a
relationship the thing is gonna die it's
gonna die an unnatural death so it is
absolutely essential that you develop
and practice good relationship care
good relationship care things like
kindness and compassion appreciation and
the consistent demonstration
of you matter to me
you matter to me now this will be
different for everyone it will be
different for different types of
relationship some people don't care if
you ever buy them a birthday present
others will die if you don't
some people can survive
a week or a monthly call others want to
hear from you every day so depending
upon the nature of the relationship
some people will need to hear i love you
and thank you
and you look really nice others could
give less than a hoot but it is up to
you
to pay enough attention to what's going
on in the relationship so that you can
do and demonstrate what's required to
nurture it to nourish it and to feed it
neglecting the people you care about and
those who care about you
that is not gonna turn out well for you
i don't care what kind of relationship
you're in
when you stop showing that you care when
you allow little slights and hurts to
add up when you stop demonstrating
respect and care and concern for one
another you are neglecting the
relationship
when you stop connecting when you stop
having fun when you stop demonstrating
appreciation these are all forms of
neglect and you know how you can tell
when the other person or the people in
the relationship are feeling neglected
they're going to start complaining they
are going to start complaining you see
the only reason we complain about
anything is because we either know or
want things to be different
we want things to be better we want
something that we're not asking for or
don't know how to ask for it's amazing
to me how much time
people spend
worrying about lamenting about their
relationship with somebody else
they spend absolutely no time developing
a relationship with themselves
so very often people want to be with
somebody because they don't want to be
by themselves well here's a question if
you don't want to be with you why does
anybody else want to be with you
what do you look like from the inside
out
do you have a clear mind do you have a
sweet spirit do you have an open heart
have you abandoned you
have you abandoned your dreams have you
abandoned your gifts
when was the last time you had an
intimate conversation with you
when was the last time you took you out
for a good evening
when was the last time you
enjoyed being home in your pjs with you
doing something fun
oh we live in a world where we expect
something or someone outside of
ourselves to make us happy
remember the only relationship that you
can ever have is a reflection of the one
you're having with yourself so if you
want somebody really good and wonderful
in your life
start with you
build that relationship
and let's see what happens
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some of the best relationship
advice you will ever get check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there we've been together a long
time that i feel like we need to spice
things up any suggestions on how to keep
the excitement alive in a long-term
relationship speaking to the microphone